Jimmy Kimmel finally goes off last night
and Jimmy Kimmel again has become sort
of the all heart the representative of
all leftist causes so we a couple of
weeks ago we broke down detail his
lecture on on healthcare reform which
was similarly based not on facts but on
emotions last night he did a long stick
about gun control that was entirely
based on emotion and it was really nasty
it was really nasty I don't know it was
nasty because he doesn't care he cares
it's really nasty because he's
suggesting the you and I don't care it
doesn't matter that you lost sleep last
night and I lost sleep last night
because of what happened it doesn't
matter that we're all heartbroken over
what happened we don't agree with Jimmy
Kimmel's evidence list suggestions about
gun control that means that we don't
care we're bad people you want to know
why the country is not unified it's
because it's stuff like this is not
because we disagree on policy we've been
disagreeing about policy forever it's
because there are certain people in the
American public discourse who feel it
necessary to imputed motives to people
who disagree and that's what Kimmel is
doing here so here's Jimmy Kimmel we're
gonna go through his entire lecture so
here he starts off ripping into
Americans who disagree well hello
everyone here we are again in the
aftermath of another terrible
inexplicable shocking and painful
tragedy this time in Las Vegas which
happens to be my hometown and cletus
hometown clio seniors hometown and as
you know at least fifty nine people are
dead hundreds of people were wounded in
what they say was the deadliest mass
shooting in modern American history
coming about a year and a half after the
previous deadliest mass shooting in
modern American history in Orlando where
forty nine people lost their lives and
of course we pray for the victims and
for their families and friends and we
wonder why even though there's probably
no way to ever know why a human being
would do something like this to other
human beings or at a concert having fun
and listening to music Jason Aldean was
onstage luke combs who is here with us
tonight he played the show too and
obviously no one could have ever
expected that something terrible would
happen but it did a very sick person
smuggled 17 guns into his hotel room and
smashed off the windows
started firing indiscriminately from the
32nd floor into a crowd of 22,000 people
across the street and as a result of
that this morning we have children
without parents and fathers without sons
mothers without daughters we lost two
police officers we lost a nurse from
Tennessee okay so oh this is fine right
everything that he's saying here is true
all of it we all feel the same thing
right we're all feeling this he doesn't
it's not a matter of him grasping the
emotion and nobody else getting the
emotion we're all feeling that some of
us show it more on the surface than
others but what he is saying is
obviously true but what's gonna be nasty
is when he swivels this and then he uses
it as a club to beat his political
opponents on gun control which happens
momentarily here sure from a local
school here in Manhattan Beach and it's
a kind of thing that it makes you want
to throw up or or give up it's too much
even process all these devastated
families do not have to live with this
pain forever because one person with the
violent and insane voice in his head
managed to stockpile a connection of a
collection of high-powered rifles and
use them to shoot people
the guy was an accountant he had no
criminal record his brother who lives in
Florida seems totally shocked genuinely
dumbfounded he said he saw no sign of
any of this the owner of the store that
sold the killer some of the rifle said
he passed the government-mandated
background check oh he was in this line
is it right there for a second he's
giving all the facts
what are these facts he just he passed a
government mandated background check no
history of mental illness his brother
didn't know anything was wrong with him
what exactly would stop something like
this right short of full gun
confiscation which is really what the
left once and we'll talk about the the
possibility of that in a second short of
that which no one on the left will admit
they want but they actually do want you
know they protest every time you say
this if you say the left wants
full-scale gun confiscation Hillary
Clinton I'll tell you know Joe Biden
will tell you no but short of full-scale
gun gun confiscation what exactly would
Jimmy can will do in a situation like
this he's gonna spell it a bunch of
policies that have nothing to do with
what actually happened in Vegas now
wasn't on any watch list and
I've been a religious of political
extremists came out of nowhere and
because of that because there weren't
any of the usual signs you know I've
been reading comments when people say
this is terrible but there's nothing we
can do about it
but I disagree with that intensely
because of course there's something we
can do about it there are a lot of
things we can do about it
but we don't which is interesting
because when someone with a beard
attacks us we tap phones we invoke
travel bans we build walls we take every
possible precaution to make sure it
doesn't happen again
but when an American buys a gun and
kills other Americans then there's
nothing we can do about that
okay so positive so Charles cook over at
National Review makes a fantastic points
about this which is Kimmel's now
undercutting his own case right because
Kimmel opposes all those things he
opposes travel bans he opposes walls he
opposes phone tapping I don't assume
that he doesn't care about terrorism I'm
sure he does he just disagrees about the
policy so why can't he grant us the same
sort of credibility we care about what
happened in Vegas we just disagree on
the policy beyond that the fact is that
when you're talking about somebody who's
a foreigner coming into the United
States and murdering people that person
does not have the same rights that you
or I do as American citizens so the sort
of measures that we have available to us
to stop them are different than the sort
of measures available to us to stop
American citizens who are using freedom
in evil ways in order to harm other
people okay
Kimmel continues second amendment I
guess our forefathers wanted us to have
a k47 is the argument I assume Orlando
Newtown Aurora San Bernardino every one
of these shootings the murder used
automatic or semi-automatic rifles which
are not weapons you use for self-defense
their weapons and designs that kill okay
not true okay so number one the founders
would have wanted us to have ar-15s
because the fact is that back in the day
all the weapons that people have were
military-grade weapons ready a musket
was a military grade weapon now ar-15s
aren't even military grade yesterday as
I said I made the mistake about
comparing basically in m16 which has
burst fire capacity with a civilian with
a civilian
AR right that's not that's not correct I
was wrong about that civilian guns are
very different from
issue guns for him to say that the
Second Amendment doesn't cover things
like ar-15s a semi-automatic rifle is
akin to me saying that the First
Amendment doesn't cover TV because the
founders had never seen a TV wouldn't
know what it looked like and don't
understand how it works it's just a
silly argument as far as the idea that
ARS are not used for home defense again
asinine I know I have a bunch of friends
who haze who use ARS for home defense
now you can find stories awr hawkins
over a Breitbart has a good good roundup
of people who have used ARS for defense
for self defense it happens on a
relatively frequent basis okay but again
you wouldn't expect yume camel to know
all of this because here is where the
left's version of common sense means
they have to be completely disconnected
from the fact arch numbers of people in
the shortest possible amount of time
this guy reportedly had 10 of them in
his room apparently legally at least
some of them were there illegally why is
that allowed I don't know why our
so-called leaders continue it allow this
to happen or maybe a better question why
do we continue to let them to allow it
to happen five people got shot in
Lawrence Kansas last night three of them
died it didn't even make a blip because
this is just a regular part of our lives
now and you know what will happen will
pray for Las Vegas some of us will get
motivated some of us won't get motivated
though bills will be written they'll be
watered down they'll fail the NRA will
smother at all with money and over time
we'll get distracted will mow on to the
next thing and then it will happen again
and again and last night one second so
again what he's saying here is also not
true when he says the NRA is gonna
smother it money the NRA is not among
the top dozen spenders in the American
political system the NRA does not give a
lot of money to politicians the NRA is a
very powerful force because there are
millions of people who are members
millions of people right the reason the
American people are not willing to to
elect representatives to repeal some of
their Second Amendment rights is because
we're not willing to do that now cuz the
NRA is bribing people it's amazing
Democrats never make this argument
unions that give tons of cash to
Democrats the unions are bribing people
but they make this argue about the NRA
that is actively not bribing people so
back to Jimmy Kimmel so Kimmel continues
along these lines and you just again all
of this is ignorant none of it is based
on knowledge about guns or firearms or
any of this stuff but this is what
passes for brilliance and
and cents in Hollywood House press
secretary Sarah sander said this is not
the time or actually it was today this
morning she said it was not the time for
political debate and I don't know we
have 59 innocent people dead it wasn't
their time either so I think now is the
time for political debate President
Trump is visiting Las Vegas on Wednesday
he spoke this morning said he's praying
for those who lost their lives you know
in February he also signed a bill that
made it easier for people with severe
mental illness to buy guns legally okay
this is not true stop it there okay so
again this is like number line number
eight in this in this little monologue
so number one again this idea that
people don't care and that's why they
don't want to talk policy maybe policy
is best talked not when you are
passionate about the issue but when
you're removed a little bit so that
you're not making the sorts of bad
arguments Jimmy Kimmel is making right
here so the bill again that trump signed
back in February did not was backed by
the ACLU it did not in fact make it
easier for mentally ill people to
purchase guns it said that a judge had
to rule you mentally incompetent before
you could have your gun taken away or
your ability to buy a gun taken away
right that's what it says the due
process is still a thing okay you don't
just get to take somebody's gone away
because you're afraid that they may be
mentally ill you actually have to show
their mentally ill before you take their
gun away people who are you know people
in the United States still have rights
until due process goes through okay time
for a few more falsehoods from Jimmy
Kimmel the Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell Speaker of the House Paul Ryan
a number of other lawmakers who won't do
anything about this because the NRA has
their balls in a money clip also sent
their thoughts and their posit the idea
that the NR a has has anybody's balls in
the money clip is just not true it is
just not true their constituents don't
want them to do the stuff Jimmy Kimmel
is talking about because the stuff Jimmy
Kimmel is talking about is not correct
okay the NRA is not bribing Paul Ryan
and Mitch McConnell again this is just
him attributing bad motives to these
politicians they don't really believe
what they believe you see they just
don't care enough and they'd rather be
paid the blood money for dead people in
Las Vegas just absurd and now it now
he's getting to the point of insulting
right because now they're all just
weaklings who if they had a shred of
heart they would do exactly what Jimmy
Kimmel wants prayers today which is is
good they should be praying they should
be praying for God to forgive them for
letting the gun lobby lobby run this
country because it is uh it's so crazy
right now there are loopholes in the law
that let people avoid background checks
if they buy a gun privately from another
party if they buy a gun online or at a
gun show so I want to show you some
reason to pause it again this is the
so-called gun show loophole it is not
correct okay the gun show loophole is it
doesn't exist
as I said before if you buy a gun at a
gun show from a federally licensed
firearms dealer they must do a
background check if you buy a gun on the
internet it is shipped to a federally
licensed firearms dealer you do a check
they do a background check before you're
allowed to take possession of the gun
all of this is true the same law is on
the books now that was on the books 50
years ago if I sell you a gun
there's no way to mandate that I do a
background check because again I have
like one gun and I'm selling it to you
or god forbid I die and I passed my guns
onto my wife right this is hand-to-hand
transfers not the same thing now you can
make the case by the way that we should
force people to do background checks I
suppose I think would be an effective
but you can make the case but it has
nothing do with happen in Vegas he
admitted earlier here that all these
guns were basically legally bought so
they again doesn't make any sense it's
just him saying that he feels more than
you feel and therefore he knows more
than you know based on the Senators who
days after the shooting Orlando voted
against a bill that would have closed
those loopholes these are the 56
senators who didn't want to do anything
about that now 90% of Democrats I'm not
talking about politicians here I'm
talking about people and 70 77 percent
of Republicans support background checks
at gun shows 89 percent of Republicans
and Democrats are in favor of
restricting gun ownership for the
mentally ill but not this gang they
voted against both of those things so
with all due respect your thoughts and
your prayers are insufficient and by the
way the House of Representatives will be
voting on a piece of legislation who
died and made Jimmy Kimmel God who who's
Jimmy Kimmel to decide whether their
thoughts your thoughts and your prayers
are insufficient so your thoughts in
your prayers are only sufficient if you
do what Jimmy Kimmel wants you to do
that's the way this works now who died
made him Jesus like it really how did
this work exactly the Jimmy Kimmel gets
to be the great moral arbiter of our
time a late night talk show host who
used to host the man show with women
bouncing on trampolines he's now the
great
of what constitutes morality and
politics and if you disagree with him
your thoughts and prayers are
insufficient it doesn't matter that you
were fervently praying for the victims
doesn't matter that you were donating
your time of your blood none of that
matters if you disagree with Jimmy
Kimmel what you've done today is
insufficient you must pay you will burn
in the fiery bowels of Jimmy Kimmel's
hell just gross this is just gross stuff
okay again I'm not doubting Jimmy Kimmel
sincerity I believe he is completely
sincere I am doubting whether it is
moral to down other people's sincerity
based on their political viewpoint he
continues we it's a bill to legalize the
sale of silencers for guns isn't what
they're working on we have a major
problem with gun violence in this
country and I guess they don't care and
if I'm wrong on that fine do something
about it because I'm sick of it and you
know why your gang he's sick of it so I
guess we're done here gang I mean as
long as he's sick of it I guess that
those rights just go out the window
again he's bring up silencers and
suppressors stupid okay there there is
no silencer or suppressor used in this
crime and if you use a suppressor which
is what what people who don't know
they're talking about call a silencer
yeah I mean the opposite if your site if
use a silencer which is what a
suppressor is all it does is it reduces
the the sound from basically a gunshot
to a jackhammer so it's still incredibly
loud again none of this has to do with
anything that just happened in Vegas but
Jimmy Kimmel's on a roll now you know
bluto's going don't don't let's stop him
now just let him let him let him roll
again this is he's sick of it he's sick
of and then he says and then he talks
about how he really wants to do comedy
but he can't because he just feels too
much sure I hate talking about stuff
like this
I just want to you know laugh about
things every night but that it seems to
becoming increasingly difficult lately
it feels like someone has opened up a
window into hell and what I'm talking
about tonight isn't about gun control
it's about common sense common sense is
no good will ever come from allowing the
person have weapons that can take down
527 Americans at a concert okay pause it
right there I know some good that can
come from those people having weapons
how about the cops who broke down the
door so this guy killed himself they all
had these kinds of weapons all of them
so clearly some people should
these weapons it's just not you right
that's what Kimmel is saying and he goes
on and we don't have to do the rest of
it but basically he suggests in the
transcript he says the NRA fought to
make sure the people on the no-fly list
can buy guns again Teddy Kennedy was on
the no-fly list the problem with no-fly
no-buy is that the no-fly list was too
broad and again there is something
called due process of law in the United
States he says that no American citizen
needs an m16 or ten of them okay
military-grade weaponry is largely
illegal for private citizens to own in
the United States we're talking about
something with automatic capacity
machine guns have been bans in the
United States since 1986 any machine gun
made after 1986 you'd illegal for you to
own under federal law and then he says
you should write your congressperson and
you should do something and then he says
he thinks it's important and he finishes
by saying you know I think it's
important okay well guess what we all
think it's important we all think it's
important but you are not an expert just
because you feel deeply you feeling
deeply does not make you an expert on a
topic it does not give you the
background expertise it's not give you
the statistical expertise to talk about
this stuff even people who study this
stuff make statistical mistakes I made
one earlier today when I have tweeted
something out and corrected it
the fact is Jimmy Kimmel doesn't even
bother with that kind of research and
the media are cheering him why because
all that matters is the feelings we
can't have a healthy body politic like
this we cannot we cannot have a healthy
body politic when the suggestion is that
people on the other side just don't give
a crap about their fellow Americans
being shot and murdered in cold blood
they're just being paid off by the NRA
that's a recipe for people out on the
streets hitting each other with clubs
that really is this is a disaster area
substituting emotion and emotional
accusations for discourse that is reason
than evidence based is a huge mistake
Jimmy Kimmel should not be cheered for
what he did last night Jimmy Kimmel
should be asked to provide the evidence
for his sub positions rather than the
evidence for his emotions again I
believe he's sincere
sincerity does not make what you're
saying smart